et à tous nous sommes très heureux de
vous accueillir ici au cedias Musée
social à Paris pour cet échange entre
les lecteurs électrices d'alternative
économique et Jean-Marc Jancovici qui
nous fait le plaisir de sa présence
nous retransmettons en direct cette
séquence sur la chaîne Youtube de
l'association sachez qu'une captation
est en cours pour les retardataires les
absents ou celles et ceux qui auraient
particulièrement goûté ce moment
merci à vous toutes et tous publics
présents ou à distance merci à la
rédaction d'Alter Eco d'être avec nous
et notamment Antoine de Ravignon je vous
présente les excuses de Timothée
Duverger président de l'association des
lecteurs d'Alter Eco retenus pour une
obligation professionnelle dans sa
tendre Gironde il nous a donc confié le
soin avec Camille Dorival Antoine
trobois et Jean-Louis Viera
au nom des membres de l'association de
vous interroger Jean-Marc Jancovici
merci d'avoir accepté de vous prêter au
jeu des questions-réponses et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
peut-être est-il désobligeant de résumer
61 ans de vie en trois minutes mais
l'exercice l'impose Jean-Marc Jancovici
vous êtes ingénieurs diplômé de l'École
Polytechnique et de télécom Paris vous
êtes le co-fondateur avec Alain
Grandjean de carbone 4 cabinet de
conseil en stratégie bacarbonne on vous
connaît aussi comme fondateur et
président du shift project sing tank
occupé à la préparation d'une économie
moindre pardon d'une économie moindre et
maîtrise de carbone
vous donnez aussi des cours des
interviews des conférences
particulièrement suivies et relayées
vous êtes aussi un auteur à succès à
l'image du monde sans fin qui à côté du
Petit Prince ou des Misérables or ne
désormais de nombreuses bibliothèques
françaises
vous réussissez la prouesse de
convaincre un large éventail politique
de l'extrême gauche à la droite en
passant par les écologistes et les
patrons du CAC 40
on l'ouvre votre sens de la pédagogie de
la formule et des métaphores ainsi que
votre souci de la démonstration
d'aucun vous reproche d'être avant tout
un soutien invétéré de la filière
nucléaire dont vous défendez
régulièrement la pertinence dans un
monde toujours plus demandeur d'énergie
la critique vise également votre
discours qui serait alarmiste ou
anxiogène et dont les effets seraient
inverses à se rechercher
parmi d'autres griefs on pointe la
corrélation rapide que vous établissez
entre repli de croissance du PIB et fin
prochaine des énergies fossiles ou
encore votre minimisation des risques
liés à la filière nucléaire
mais on vous reconnaît d'avoir
repositionné le sujet de l'énergie et de
la sobriété au cœur des débats
politiques voire peut-être des
consciences citoyennes vous prenez une
décarbonation plutôt voulue que subit
qui selon vous nous guetterait si nous
ne changions pas de modèle et d'habitude
de consommation votre pensée dépasse
donc la seule question énergétique et
vos avis sont entendus sur le climat la
croissance la démocratie les choix de
société la sobriété sujet sur lesquels
nous aurons le plaisir de revenir tout à
l'heure en compagnie de trois autres
membres de l'association des lecteurs
d'Alternatives économiques nous
commencerons avec Jean-Louis vira
avec qui vous converserez sur la
sobriété
puis Antoine trobois à propos du mix
énergétique des ENR et du nucléaire et
nous finirons avec Camille de rival qui
vous interrogera sur la démocratie des
choix techniques
quelques éléments de cadrage en
préambule de ces discussions dont nous
nous réjouissons toutes et tous merci
aux jne qui nous appuie aujourd'hui pour
la captation cette soirée est un échange
entre les lecteurs d'Alter echo et
Jean-Marc Jancovici dont nous espérons
profiter des éclairages nous plaçons
donc cet échange sous le signe de
l'ouverture de la neutralité sans
polémique et sans parti pris
nous avons réservé un temps de questions
posées par les personnes présentes dans
la salle qui bien entendu je n'en doute
pas s'attacheront à les faire très
courte
nous ne pourrons malheureusement pas
prendre de questions en ligne
j'assume aussi le rôle de gardien du
temps qui me donnera le pouvoir char
Jean-Marc de vous inviter peut-être à
écourter certaines réponses ou à vous
relancer je vous remercie toutes et tous
de votre attention
et je donne la parole pour la première
séquence de ce face à face à Jean-Louis
Virat qui aura la charge de poser
quelques questions à Jean-Marc Jancovici
sur la question de la sobriété je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
le micro fonctionne oui très bien
bonsoir Monsieur Jean-Côme ici merci
d'être avec nous effectivement nous
sommes très très curieux de toutes les
réponses que vous allez pouvoir nous
faire en commençant par la sobriété
effectivement on s'aperçoit que les
constats des scientifiques sont sans
appel donc je crois que il y a pas de il
y a pas discuter et quand on parle de
sobriété ça pose certainement une
question de de choix de société quelle
façon de vivre nous nous envisageons
d'avoir entre grosso modo le
consumérisme
qui a cours actuellement et des formes
de sociétés inventées beaucoup plus
conviviales
simple et faites d'entraide alors trois
questions dans dans ce cadre là la
première c'est
quels sont selon vous les les scénarios
les études prospectives les plus
les plus
dignes de confiance en quelque sorte les
scénarios de référence que nous devons
nous citoyen de base à voir pour
réfléchir et prendre des décisions
avant de répondre à la question je vais
peut-être commencer par donner ma
définition du mot sobriété
pour moi la sobriété elle n'a pas besoin
d'adjectif derrière donc je sais pas si
elle est heureuse ou malheureuse elle a
une définition qui est assez simple
c'est l'abandon volontaire d'un service
permettant d'économiser derrière et
j'insiste sur volontaire permettant
d'économiser derrière l'énergie et les
matières qui ont permis de fournir le
bien ou le service
je la distingue de l'efficacité qui ne
consiste pas à abandonner quoi que ce
soit mais qui est un en haut une
amélioration technique du bien ou du
service et je la distingue également de
la pauvreté qui en terme physique
ressemble à la sobriété sauf que c'est
subi et pas voulu donc en fait il y a
trois manières pour moi d'économiser de
l'énergie ou d'économiser des ressources
l'efficacité qui était sorti repose
essentiellement sur la filière
productive donc en gros on veut toujours
la même voiture hébergeant toujours la
grand-mère et le canari quand on part en
vacances
allant toujours la même vitesse offrant
toujours l'autoradio mais il faut que
les ingénieurs se débrouillent pour que
ça consomme moins d'énergie ou pas la
même ou etc
la deuxième
ça c'est l'efficacité la sobriété c'est
je ne prends pas la voiture pour partir
en vacances et je pars en vacances en
vélo en train je pars pas en vacances
enfin voilà dans le but délibérément
d'éviter le la consommation et là pour
voter c'est je pars pas en vacances
parce que j'ai pas les moyens mais
j'aurais bien aimé donc c'est j'insiste
sur le fait que la sobriété est
nécessairement volontaire et que dès
qu'on est dans la sobriété subisse
s'appelle de la pauvreté je distinguais
important pour moi
ensuite pour répondre à la question sur
les scénarios alors un scénario il y a
un gros malentendu sur les scénarios un
scénario n'est pas une prévision un
scénario c'est une boîte à casser pour
aider à réfléchir à l'avenir
ça n'est pas une prévision d'accord
quand Météo France vous fait une vous
dit quel est le temps qu'il va faire
demain c'est pas un scénario
météorologique c'est une prévision alors
il vous dit ça va se passer comme ça
quand un astronome vous dit où sera la
terre autour de l'orbite du surf à
hauteur du soleil dans trois ans deux
mois trois semaines deux heures et 5
secondes c'est une prévision d'accord on
applique les lois de la mécanique un
scénario c'est pas une prévision donc à
chaque fois que quelqu'un dit parce que
le scénario dit que c'est possible non
un scénario dit pas que c'est possible
un scénario j'insiste c'est une boîte à
casser qui permet d'explorer l'avenir et
de regarder c'est du c'est du c'est du
ce que les Anglais appellent du whatiffe
d'accord c'est si nous avons ça alors
nous avons ça derrière un scénario c'est
aussi vraisemblable que les hypothèses
qu'on met en entrée et aussi
vraisemblable que les lois d'évolution
qu'on utilise à l'intérieur du scénario
ni plus ni moins
alors en ce qui concerne les scénarios
qu'on a aujourd'hui sur l'avenir il
partage tous pour moi un certain nombre
de faiblesses je dis bien absolument
tous et il y en a une qui va beaucoup
vous intéresser puisque nous sommes ici
par des gens au sein de l'assistance qui
normalement est intéressé par l'économie
c'est que il présuppose tous que nous
conservons dans un monde qui va avoir de
beaucoup de moins en moins d'énergie
la productivité industrielle que nous
avons acquise dans un monde qui a
énormément d'énergie alors je vais
prendre un exemple on en parlera de tout
à l'heure peut-être sur les EnR mais
quand on dit aujourd'hui le coût d'une
NRB baisse en fait la démonstration
qu'on a faite c'est qu'on a réussi à le
faire baisser dans un monde qui continue
à être dopé au combustible fossiles ça
ne présuppose pas que cette baisse de
cours reste acquise dans un monde où les
engins de mines n'ont plus de pétrole il
y a plus de porte-conteneurs pour
transbahuter les pièces d'un continent à
l'autre il y a plus de camions en même
quantité pour transbahuter les pièces
d'une usine à une autre il y a plus de
pétrole pour mettre dans les grues qui
érigent les éoliennes etc d'accord on
sait pas ce que donne le prix dans ce
genre de monde là donc la partie
économique des scénarios pour moi elle
est faible
dans tous les scénarios que je connais
parce que dans tous les scénarios que je
connais il y a une incohérence entre le
paysage global dans lequel on baisse la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise et la
conséquence logique qu'il faudrait en
tirer qui est que moins d'énergie c'est
moins de machines au travail et moins de
machines au travail c'est une
productivité industrielle qui baisse
vous avez plein de trucs qu'on prévoit
pas dans les scénarios du reste ces
derniers temps vous avez bien vu par
exemple dans dans le budget carbone qui
reste à l'humanité pour pas dépasser 1,5
degrés il vient de diviser par 2
jusqu'à maintenant on raisonnait avec un
scénario dans lequel il était de 600
milliards de tonnes de CO2 on avait
encore le droit d'émettre 600 milliards
de tonnes de CO2 avant d'atteindre pof
c'est passé à 300 donc j'insiste sur ce
qui est une très mauvaise nouvelle mais
donc j'insiste sur le fait que un
scénario n'est encore une fois
pas plus vraisemblable et pas moins ni
plus ni moins que les hypothèses qu'on a
mises en entrée et les lois d'évolution
ce qui fait que pour réfuter un scénario
vous n'avez malheureusement pas d'autres
solutions que et du reste on en parlera
tout à l'heure dans le sujet de la
démocratie soit de le lire vous-même
et d'aller vous palucher vous-même la
vérification de toutes les hypothèses
une par une et toutes les lois
d'évolution une par une d'accord ça
c'est l'option a l'option B faire
confiance à quelqu'un qui va faire ça
pour vous et en qui vous savez que vous
pouvez avoir confiance parce que vous
avez déjà vérifié dans un autre cas de
figure qu'il y a pas de différence entre
un truc que vous êtes allé regarder
vous-même dans même juste dans le même
domaine évidemment et un truc
qui l'a dit se tire de confiance mais
vous êtes coincé vous avez pas d'autres
moyens donc c'est le tiers de confiance
ou c'est la lecture en direct voilà et
donc ce que j'en pense je le redis c'est
que j'insiste sur le fait que ça n'est
que des boîtes à casser qui sont
aujourd'hui encore très incomplètes sur
les bouclages globaux très arrangé
pour réfléchir parce que on n'est pas on
n'a pas la science infuse au sens large
du terme et donc on a souvent l'habitude
à te voir raison d'ailleurs vous allez
peut-être nous le dire de nous référer
aux quatre scénarios de la dame avec en
gros
se penche du côté d'une certaine forme
de sobriété en tenant compte d'ailleurs
de ce que vous avez dit ou à l'inverse
des scénarios beaucoup plus technicistes
quel serait votre votre réaction votre
avis votre préférence par rapport à en
gros ces deux catégories de scénarios
alors je vais plutôt c'est beaucoup plus
facile de donner un avis sur ce à quoi
on ne croit pas que ce à quoi on croit
donc je vais commencer par dire ce à
quoi je ne crois pas dans les scénarios
de la dame et on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure tous ceux qui sont
rapidement enfin qui sont très sobre
reste quand même des scénarios de
croissance économique alors
tant que le PIB mesure la même chose
j'insiste parce qu'il y a des tas de
moyens de lui faire mesurer autre chose
donc on peut décider par exemple qu'on
supprime la notion d'inflation à ce
moment on peut avoir un PIB
éternellement croissant ça pose aucun
problème même avec une consommation
matérielle décroissante mais tant que on
a quelque chose qui qui mesure toujours
la même chose
moi je ne crois pas dans un monde avec
de moins en moins d'énergie et de moins
en moins de machines à une productivité
du travail qui continue d'augmenter la
productivité du travail industriel ça
n'a été rien d'autre que de mettre des
machines en plus des hommes je veux dire
les ouvriers aujourd'hui ils ont pas 43
paires de bras et 26 paires de jambes
alors qu'ils en avaient qu'une chacun
perd de bras et paire de jambes il y a
un siècle donc s'ils sont devenus
considérablement plus productifs c'est
juste que les machines bossent à leur
place si un ouvrier métallurgiste
aujourd'hui et des milliers de fois plus
productifs pour produire de l'acier dans
un haut fourneau que ça n'était le cas
avec les loupes en fonte il y a quelques
siècles encore une fois c'est pas parce
que il aura poussé des bras et des
jambes et que ils ont des tels poumons
qui font les soufflets de forges tout
seul c'est bien parce que aujourd'hui
c'est le haut fourneau
et le laminoir qui produisent l'acier
c'est pas l'ouvrier vous voyez il est là
pour donner des ordres à la machine donc
dans un monde avec de moins en moins
d'énergie l'idée qu'on va conserver une
productivité du travail importante est
un problème donc ça c'est il y a ça dans
les quatre scénarios de l'ADEME bon donc
c'est quand même une hypothèse qui est
un peu gênante parce qu'il y a un petit
coup de baguette magique là-dedans qui
permet derrière de rendre possible
l'état de trucs ici on enlève cette
hypothèse 16 d'être possible et j'ai pas
corrigé les scénarios de cette hypothèse
là d'accord j'ai pas Facebook alors
après ce à quoi je ne crois pas c'est au
fait que sur une planète qui fait
désespérément 13000 km de diamètre on va
avoir de plus en plus de flux de matière
de toute façon j'y crois pas et de plus
en plus de flux d'énergie je suis même
capable de démontrer l'inverse il y a un
petit théorème de maths qui permet de
démontrer
donc ce que je crois c'est que il faut
rendre désirable une baisse de la
consommation matérielle que de toute
façon on va devoir gérer
et cette baisse de la consommation
matérielle le il faut mais ça ça dépend
des secteurs faire une combinaison entre
efficacité et sobriété en gros on
ramasse tout ce que l'efficacité nous
donne et on boucle avec de la sobriété
en gros c'est comme ça qu'il faut
arriver à faire les choses mais toujours
dans les trucs intéressants à noter il
vous aura pas échappé que en général
quand l'économie va entre guillemets pas
bien c'est à dire que on est en
récession etc la rotation du capital
ralentit
quand la rotation du capital ralentit
par exemple les voitures se renouvellent
moins vite les ordinateurs se
renouvellent moins vite etc du coup ça
limite la pénétration du progrès
technique parce que pour que le progrès
technique pénètre il faut renouveler les
parcs
d'accord pour que les voitures
deviennent plus efficaces faut les
remplacer donc il faut renouveler les
parcs pour que les ordinateurs et les
mixeur à souple deviennent plus
efficaces les tourniquettes à faire la
vinaigrette comme disait bien et bien il
faut les remplacer donc il y a là aussi
quelque chose que souvent dans les
scénarios qui sont très volontaristes
sur l'efficacité énergétique en fait il
ne boucle pas avec l'énergie nécessaire
au sein de l'industrie
pour fabriquer à toute vapeur c'est le
cas de le dire tous les objets qui vont
devoir être nécessaires pour remplacer
des objets existants enfin voilà il y a
des choses de cette nature qui ne sont
malheureusement pas dans les dans les
approches donc moi je crois que on va
devoir faire avec moi je vais vous
donner un autre exemple de trucs qui est
pas pris en compte aujourd'hui quand en
1800 la totalité de l'économie mondiale
donc française en particulier tournait
avec 9 éléments du tableau de Mendeleïev
le fer le cuivre le plomb l'étain le
carbone l'oxygène et j'en oublie trois
j'ai plus que c'était bon bref
alors à laquelle je vous parle les 92
éléments du tableau de mandalief en des
applications industrielles les 92 ce qui
veut dire que rien que votre chemise ou
mon polo sont indirectement dépendants
des 92 parce que le type qui m'a vendu
ce polo il a de l'informatique chez lui
dans l'informatique si la plus
d'ordinateur chez lui qui retourne à
papier crayon pour gérer ils vont pas
autant de polo
etc donc en fait il faut bien voir
qu'aujourd'hui on a créé une économie
mondialisée et une bonne partie des
progrès techniques sur lesquels on
compte à l'avenir postule que cette
mondialisation perdure parce que cette
mondialisation est nécessaire pour
extraire les 92 éléments du tableau de
Mendeleïev là où il se trouve
en France par exemple un pain de cuivre
en France on a plus de mine de fer on
pourrait en ouvrir on sera pas très
bonne mais enfin bon on n'aurait pas
beaucoup
en France on a plus de plomb on a plus
d'éteindre on a plus on reste un peu de
bauxite dans le sud-est etc mais vous
voyez donc en fait comment est-ce qu'on
fait dans une économie qui se
démondialise et beaucoup moins de
pétrole c'est une démondialisation parce
que c'est porte-conteneurs et minéral
alliés les braquiers c'est tout ça c'est
du pétrole comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour conserver ce qu'on appelle le
progrès technique c'est-à-dire des
objets très sophistiqués voilà est-ce
que la dame s'est penchée dans le
scénario sobriété sur la possibilité ne
serait-ce que de continuer à faire des
machines à laver qui aujourd'hui
comporte aussi 60 éléments ou 80
éléments différents parce qu'ils ont
elles ont un tableau numérique etc non
voilà donc c'est tout ça pour dire que
aujourd'hui on est encore sur des
visions qui sont très très rustiques
très embryonnaires très macroscopiques
en fait elles sont utiles pour inspirer
des travaux techniques sectoriels etc
mais elles ne peuvent pas en l'état
constituer ce que j'appellerai une
solution c'est à dire on sort ce truc là
on dit y'a qu'à faire ce truc là le
scénario B2 de RTE enfin le scénario M3
ou m2 de RTE et le scénario machin de la
dame et puis ça va non non
malheureusement il reste beaucoup de de
de d'angle mort et de et d'effet de
rétroaction qu'on a pas pris en compte
dans dans les approches qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui mais je le redis ça peut
constituer une source d'inspiration
utile pour les gens les soutiers qui
sont à l'étage en dessous et qui eux
doivent réfléchir qu'est-ce que je fais
comme voiture dans un monde où il y a
moins de mondialisation ou c'est moins
facile d'extraire le métal des mines ou
la productivité industrielle diminue et
ou de ça doit pas émettre de CO2 voilà
comme ça alors au fond par rapport à ma
question vous nous mettez en face d'une
sobriété qui reste complètement inventée
et
pas complètement mais en grande partie
quand même notamment sur plan social
parce qu'il faut qu'il y a un consensus
à votre avis il vaut mieux prendre le
problème par le par quel bout par le
haut ou par le bas en quelque sorte
alors ça on va peut-être en parler avec
ma voisine de droite mais par le bas
pour moi
je crois fortement que la démocratie est
un système remontant sinon ça s'appelle
une dictature et donc je pense que il
faut prendre le problème par le bas
merci peut-être une dernière question
est-ce que il faut croire dans les
avancées technologiques pour solutionner
nos problèmes au-delà des ressources que
ça nécessite alors si on refait
aujourd'hui des machines à laver dans
lesquelles vous avez une commande
électromécanique
et un tambour dans lequel vous avez un
alliage très simple et un capot pas en
plastique mais en bois je dis n'importe
quoi
c'est tout à fait une avancée technique
d'accord donc est-ce que je crois aux
avancées techniques oui est-ce que je
crois à là avec un grand l technique
avec inventé en fait ça n'est pas défini
la technique avec un Grand T ça ça
n'existe même pas non est-ce que je
crois qu'on va pouvoir compter sur des
objets de plus en plus complexes je
viens d'expliquer juste avant que non
pour la raison à laquelle je
qu'est-ce que ça signifie pour un pays
comme la France qui n'a quasiment plus
une mine sur son sol
pour une zone comme l'Europe qui n'a
quasiment plus une mine sur enfin si il
y a encore des mines en Europe mais à
l'est et au nord mais il y en a quand
même plus énormément
et qui est aujourd'hui critiquement
dépendantes des approvisionnements en
matière première pour tout et n'importe
quoi de ce qui se passe à l'étranger ça
ça reste à inventer alors que ça demande
beaucoup d'ingéniosité de réfléchir à la
façon dont on construit ce système en
essayant de conserver un minimum d'Aki
pour qu'on trouve pas la potion trop
amère c'est évident que ça va demander
beaucoup beaucoup d'ingéniosité mais
c'est pas le cahier des charges avec
lequel on fonctionne aujourd'hui
c'est pas là qu'on met notre jus de
cerveau aujourd'hui
très bien merci beaucoup on arrive au
bout de la première séquence consacrée à
la sobriété au mode de consommation je
donne la parole juste avec la ville
d'escalier il y a un truc quand même
c'est que on dit toujours la sobriété
est heureuse moi je vois pas je suis pas
d'accord du tout aujourd'hui ce qui est
heureux c'est la consommation quand vous
regardez le comportement effectif des
gens ce qui est heureux c'est la
consommation je veux dire les gens se
précipitent sur les promotions etc les
buffets à volonté bon donc je pense
qu'il y a un énorme il y a un énorme
travail culturel à faire et pas du tout
un travail d'ingénieur là je rentre de
l'Université d'été enfin en l'occurrence
qui s'est tenu à la fin du printemps des
shifters qui sont les bénévoles du shift
qui constituent une association
distincte à Nantes et le et le
le thème de cette année c'était comment
créer du récit
autour de cette histoire de transition
des carbonation de sobriété etc et
aujourd'hui on en manque cruellement on
continue vous ouvrez à Télé ce que je
fais de temps en temps parce que c'est
intéressant de regarder ce qui y passe
vous continuez serait pas une série
policière où il est pas j'ai remarqué ça
même française on y est pas un 4x4 une
Jaguar ou je sais pas quoi donc on est
on est dans un on continue à être dans
un imaginaire un véhiculé un imaginaire
Hollywood est une entreprise marketing
extraordinaire pour pousser les gens à
consommer donc il y a pas c'était
partiellement assumé du reste un moment
donc il y a un énorme sujet culturel
j'ai envie de dire lié à qu'est-ce qui
fait que les gens peuvent être heureux
en montant sur un vélo plutôt qu'en
montant dans une voiture voilà je pense
que c'est la question qu'il faut se
poser c'est la question qu'il faut se
poser
pardon merci alors ce qui sous-tend tout
ça et tous nos toutes nos habitudes
c'est aussi les consommations d'énergie
qu'il faut donc avant de les consommer
les produire aujourd'hui on a une
tradition en France qui est très
nucléaire mais on est aussi conscient
d'un virage nécessaire vers les énergies
renouvelables je laisse Antoine poser la
première question de la deuxième
séquence merci bonsoir Jean-Marc
chocovici donc si on a vu que la
sobriété n'est plus vraiment une option
on constate aussi aujourd'hui que c'est
une option et l'autre option ça sera de
la pauvreté
merci
on constate que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui voudrait dépasser
l'opposition à ces traditionnelles en
France entre énergie renouvelables et
nucléaire en proposant d'accélérer en
même temps le développement des EnR
terrestre comme offshore et de relancer
le nouveau nucléaire Argan d'horizon de
temps différent pour déployer ces moyens
de production électrique des carbonnés à
savoir plus rapide pour les EnR
terrestres et aux liens et solaire et
moins rapide pour l'éolien offshore et
le nouveau nucléaire donc ma première
question est-ce que faire justement feu
tout bois sur l'électrification des
usages les EnR et le nucléaire et la
seule solution possible pour répondre
aux enjeux actuels
je vais vous faire une réponse de type
mots mêlé là vous savez les mots mêlés
vous barrez tous les mots etc puis à la
fin il vous reste les lettres pour
composer le mot que vous devez trouver
bon donc là on va barrer d'accord
qu'est-ce qu'on a comme option dans un
monde qu'on veut des carboner et dans un
monde dans lequel de toute façon pour
des raisons géologiques
l'approvisionnement pétrolier et gazier
et plus tard charbonnier va de toute
façon baisser ainsi d'amant en Europe la
provisionnement pétrolier baisse déjà de
manière subie depuis 2008
l'approvisionnement gazier baisse déjà
de manière subie depuis entre 2005 et
2010 voilà la conséquence la raison pour
le pétrole c'est le pic de production du
pétrole conventionnel dans le monde 2008
et la raison pour le gaz c'est le pic de
production de la mer du Nord qui faisait
plus de la moitié du gaz européen en
donc on est déjà dans une baisse subite
des deux ça se voit de manière très très
simple et c'est la raison incidament
pour laquelle la production industrielle
donc demande plus en Europe que la
construction on augmente plus en Europe
que les tonnes chargées dans les camions
on augmente plus en Europe et que le
revenu disponible des ménages français a
commencé à s'éroder depuis 2010 voilà
tout ça tout ça est une affaire
d'énergie de façon on peut l'expliquer
de façon assez assez simple
donc dans cette affaire là il y a un
donc on peut pas utiliser les énergies
fossiles d'abord parce qu'on en a de
moins en moins et ensuite parce que
elles émettent du CO2 dans les énergies
bas carbone il en reste deux
enfin deux catégories il y a les
énergies qui renouvelables et les
énergies dites nucléaires je dis les
parce qu'il y a plusieurs manières
d'exploiter l'énergie nucléaire
il faut quand même commencer par
rappeler que l'essentiel de
l'approvisionnement énergétique direct
de la France et fossile
et si je prends l'empreinte carbone des
Français c'est à dire l'énergie qui a
été nécessaire hors des frontières pour
toutes les fringues que vous portez et
moi aussi toutes les chaussures que vous
portez et moi aussi les pieds en acier
des chaises sur lesquelles vous êtes
assis les voitures dans lesquelles vous
êtes venus qui sont faites en acier qui
a pas été le minerai de fer vient pas de
France les casseroles que vous avez
achetées chez un distributeur que je ne
nommerai pas qui sont made in ailleurs
tout autant qu'elles sont les
smartphones qui n'a pas de smartphone
dans la salle
voilà
un valeureux candidat là-bas donc c'est
c'est l'énergie de fabrication elle a
pas eu lieu en France etc donc si je
rajoute l'énergie de fabrication c'est à
dire l'empreinte carbone de ce qui vient
dehors de France la France est encore
plus fossile que si je regarde
simplement son énergie direct donc en
fait il faut la première chose qu'il
faut commencer par rappeler c'est que
l'électricité en France
c'est un petit cas de l'énergie qu'on
consomme directement en France l'énergie
finale et si je rajoute l'énergie qu'on
consomme pas en France et qui est
nécessaire à nos biens de consommation
c'est en dessous de 20%
et ça fait depuis que je m'intéresse au
sujet d'énergie que pardonnez-moi
l'expression on se contrefout alors
maintenant c'est un peu moins vrai
comment ça s'occuper un peu du gaz mais
que on se contrefout totalement
du sujet pétrole et qu'on se calme sur
l'électricité voilà alors il y a
plusieurs raisons à ça à mon avis
la plus évidente pour moi c'est que les
médias en particulier audiovisuel ne
pouvant faire des reportages que sur des
trucs qui se voient les seuls trucs qui
se voient en France et les centrales
électriques parce qu'on n'a pas de pluie
de pétrole on n'a pas de mine de charbon
et on n'a pas de pluie de gaz et donc on
s'occupe de parler d'électricité voilà
je pense que c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles le débat c'est fortement
focalisé là-dessus parce que c'est voilà
c'est facile de faire un reportage sur
un truc qui existe plus difficile sur un
truc qui n'existe pas
si on veut se débarrasser des
combustibles fossiles on a deux options
on a une première option qui est la
sobriété ou si on traîne trop la
pauvreté donc la sobriété c'est je le
redis j'arrête la voiture et je prends
vélo marche à pied train la voiture du
voisin water
la version pauvreté c'est je deviens
gilet jaune la même chose
et puis on a l'électrification à base
d'électricité bas carbone aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les temps de
développement à la fois du nucléaire que
j'aime beaucoup et des renouvelables que
j'aime parfois
de toute façon les temps sont beaucoup
trop longs pour qu'on puisse compter que
sur ça à consommation d'énergie
identique donc en fait le premier boulot
enfin je veux dire ça sert à rien
d'essayer d'électrifier à consommation
énergétique identique on y arrivera pas
donc ça veut dire que en fait en ce
moment on prend l'option que le problème
finisse par se régler progressivement
par de la pauvreté c'est ça qui se passe
pour électrifier qu'est-ce qu'on utilise
bah en fait je vais refaire un peu la
même réponse que celle que j'ai faite
pour mon raisin de gauche ça dépend
si vous voulez décarboner la production
d'acier il faut l'équivalent de la
production électrique d'un réacteur
nucléaire par au fourneau qu'on passe à
la réduction directe à l'hydrogène
je pense que c'est plus simple de
construire rapidement des réacteurs
nucléaires à côté des hauts fourneaux
que d'essayer de connecter ça à des
sources intermittentes sans compter
qu'un ce genre de procédé c'est des
procédés en continu industriels etc
compliqué à débrancher
si vous avez besoin de clim c'est
vachement bien de mettre un panneau
solaire sur la maison parce qu'en
général vous avez besoin de clim quand
il fait chaud il fait chaud quand il y a
du soleil
donc ce que ce qu'on ne fait pas
suffisamment aujourd'hui si on oppose
pas tout ça c'est d'essayer de raisonner
sur quel est le truc le plus pertinent
en fonction de l'application qu'on veut
en faire derrière et par ailleurs si on
compte nos abattis combien est-ce qu'on
peut raisonnablement en faire
voilà et dans le raisonnablement là je
vais peut-être vous faire sauter les
sauter en l'air mais il y a un truc
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire en
matière ni de renouvelable ni nucléaire
c'est d'accepter l'idée que on se dirige
vers un monde qui va de toute façon être
très risqué de toute façon être très
risqué et que la seule chose qu'on
puisse faire c'est un arbitrage des
risques mais l'idée que j'ai longtemps
combattu maintenant c'est un peu moins
que un monde sans nucléaire est un monde
sans risque est à mon avis c'est pas
vrai du tout un monde sans nucléaire il
y a plein d'autres risques que le risque
nucléaire on augmente plein d'autres
risques en disant qu'on va faire sans
nucléaire on augmente plein d'autres et
à l'arrivée mon analyse c'est que le
monde global est beaucoup plus risqué si
on en fait pas voilà
effectivement donc on va récupérer les
risques du nucléaires mais on va en
diminuer plein d'autres c'est un peu
comme si vous refusez les effets
secondaires d'un médicament qui va vous
sauver la vie
si vous voulez un médicament c'est
risqué je vous rappelle qu'il va au dos
c'est toujours du poison c'est la même
chose bon donc sauf que vous allez
arbitrer les risques et vous allez dire
est-ce que je prends le risque du
médicament ou le risque de pas prendre
le médicament et très souvent vous allez
prendre le risque du médicament bon là
c'est exactement pareil ce qu'on ne sait
pas faire aujourd'hui dans le débat sur
l'énergie en particulier sur l'énergie
nucléaire c'est faire l'arbitrage des
risques donc on ne voit que les risques
d'une option et on voit pas les risques
des autres options donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire feu de tout bois oui mais en
étant discriminé et discriminer ça veut
dire que par exemple bonjour on va
rentrer dans les détails
de l'éolien ici c'est intelligent de
l'éolien là c'est moins intelligent de
l'éolien pour avoir de l'électricité
quand le vent souffle c'est bien pour en
avoir quand le vent souffle pas
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué
enfin voilà donc et en particulier un
des trucs aujourd'hui on ne sait pas
faire dans un dans un dans un réseau qui
serait essentiellement alimenté avec des
sources non pilotables c'est le stockage
inters saisonnier ou le stockage interne
c'est ça les grosses difficultés le
stockage quotidien on va y arriver c'est
pas un problème il y a des batteries etc
le vrai problème c'est passer les
saisons et éventuellement passer les
années qui ont des conditions
météorologiques assez différenciées
voilà c'est ça le ça de la différence
merci ouais justement pour poursuivre
sur la notion de risque nous on vous
propose maintenant de zoomer en fait sur
les handicaps de chaque source d'énergie
électrique des carbonées donc ENR puis
nucléaire parce que mettre en avant en
fait les atouts les lobby le font tous
les jours donc nous en tant que citoyens
on considère justement que c'est dans
les angles morts technologiques ou
sociétaux que va se cacher le diable
donc quel serait selon vous les
handicaps majeurs qui pèsent sur une
forte pénétration des ENR électrique
est-ce justement la maîtrise des
technologies de stockage comme
l'hydrogène ou le ou le méthane de
synthèse est-ce que c'est
l'approvisionnement matériaux la
maintenance la durée de vie de ces
installations encore le manque d'espace
ou bien l'acceptation sociétale des
éoliennes par exemple
alors d'abord il faut rappeler que dans
les EnR électrique la première dans le
monde aujourd'hui c'est
l'hydroélectricité d'accord donc en fait
votre question je vais la restreindre
électrique non pilotable que sont
l'éolien et de solaire parce que
j'imagine que c'est essentiellement
là-dessus qu'elle portait il y a aucun
problème pour faire un système 100% ENR
quand vous êtes en Norvège le reste
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
ils sont 4 millions et demi sur un
territoire qui doit faire sauf erreur de
ma part un peu moins de 200000 de
l'ordre de 200 ou 250 000 km² qui est
essentiellement montagneux il consomme
2,5 fois si la mémoire est bonne
l'électricité des Français par personne
100% erdr aucun problème voilà donc il y
a des géographies qui s'y prêtent très
bien il y a aucun problème et le
électricité étant pilotable il y a zéro
zéro souci en ce qui concerne l'éolien
et le solaire alors les inconvénients on
va dire par rapport aux formes plus
historiques de production électrique
qu'on a c'est que c'est des c'est des
sources qui fasse ça exploite des
sources d'énergie qui sont diffuses il y
a pas beaucoup d'énergie dans un mètre
cube de vent qui se déplace et il y a
pas beaucoup d'énergie dans un mètre
carré qui reçoit de l'énergie solaire
d'accord il y en a pas énormément donc
ça veut dire que pour avoir des
quantités significatives d'énergie à
partir de ces sources et aujourd'hui
notre civilisation utilise des quantités
très significatives d'énergie même si on
divisé par deux ou par 3 ça serait
encore des quantités très significatives
d'énergie par rapport à ce qu'on était
les temps historiques par rapport à ce
qui était la condition humaine il y a
plus de deux siècles et ça demande de
déployer un très très grand nombre de
connecteurs du coup ça donc le premier
le premier sujet c'est les matériaux
l'industrie les emplacements donc tous
les trucs qui sont nécessaires quand
vous avez un très très grand nombre de
collecteurs à déployer et ça ça peut
être un sujet en tant que tel quand vous
regardez la quantité d'éolien au sort
qu'il faudrait la quantité d'éolienne
qu'il faudrait avoir pour avoir 50 ou
100 gigawatts de puissance installés va
vous vous rendez compte que on en
parcelle tout le long des côtes
absolument partout
c'est pas nécessairement très facile
d'abord il y a un sujet d'acceptabilité
mais même s'il acceptabilité n'est pas
un problème ça veut dire que il y a
plein d'endroits où il faut faire des
chantiers offshore est-ce qu'on a les
moyens de les faire en simultané pas
nécessairement ça veut dire qu'il faut
créer plein de bateaux pour aller
installer faire des trous et des machins
etc avoir plein de cimenterie qui savent
faire du béton qui solidifie sous l'eau
il y a des histoires de filières
industrielles
où il peut y avoir également des
facteurs limitants et ensuite ces
installations on les faits pour 20 ans
30 ans alors bon c'est comme pour le
nucléaire qu'on a dit 40 ans il va durer
plus longtemps une éolienne on dit 20
ans en fait ça va durer plus longtemps
certains nombres c'est évident mais à un
moment va quand même falloir le
renouveler donc le la question aussi
c'est qu'on construit un système
électrique ok on a des scénarios en 2050
mais en fait le système électrique qu'on
construit il doit durer jusqu'en 3250
en fait si on réfléchit bien une fois
qu'on aura fait un truc stable
il va devoir durer très longtemps donc
il y a un vrai sujet de flux de
renouvellement continu sur lequel
aujourd'hui je crois que peu de gens se
penchent qui nécessitent en permanence
de renouveler des approvisionnements
en compétence en matériaux alors il y a
une partie des trucs qu'on va pouvoir
recycler un mas d'éoliennes en acier on
peut en faire un autre made éolienne en
acier pas de problème il y a des trucs
qui sont plus difficiles à recycler par
exemple tous les métaux qui sont des
petits métaux de spécialités qui sont
diffus dans les pièces de l'éolienne
cela se recycle plus difficilement il
faut savoir que dans les métaux
spécialités il y a un papier qui est
sorti il y a pas longtemps montrant que
pour une cinquantaine ou une soixantaine
d'entre eux la dilution dans les objets
qui en contiennent est supérieur à la
dilution dans les mines qui contiennent
ces métaux ce qui veut dire que le
recyclage de ces métaux à partir des
objets qui en contiennent va être
extrêmement difficile extrêmement
difficile
ça va être très consommateur d'énergie
donc très difficile
voilà donc il y a et puis en fait il y a
le le sujet alors le solaire c'est
pareil il faut des emplacements quantité
significative on voit bien aujourd'hui
qui commence à y avoir des conflits
d'usage avec des gens qui veulent mettre
des grands parcs dans les forêts dans
l'agriculture etc les terres agricoles
aujourd'hui on peut en libérer pour
mettre des panneaux tout simplement
parce que on a rendu l'agriculture très
productive avec des tracteurs des
phytosanitaires et des engrais le jour
où l'agriculture devient beaucoup moins
productive parce qu'on a beaucoup moins
de tout ça
est-ce que on a la même vue sur
l'occupation c'est pareil on renvoie la
question des scénarios ça c'est un truc
qui est pas bouclé dans les scénarios en
général on continue à voir le gisement
de biomasse à l'avenir en particulier
agricole comme si on avait ad vitam
eternam des engrais de synthèse des
phytosanitaires et des tracteurs bah
peut-être que oui peut-être que non bon
voilà donc c'est ça le sujet c'est que
ça demande beaucoup de collecteurs
et donc ça demande beaucoup de matériaux
beaucoup d'emplacements et la pérennité
à terme de la possibilité de maintenir
un parc avec beaucoup de collecteurs et
beaucoup d'emplacements aujourd'hui
c'est un angle mort c'est une question
qu'on n'a pas exploré
la deuxième la deuxième sujet c'est
l'intermittence c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on s'est habitué à avoir
l'électricité qui alimente la caméra
alors à laquelle on fait mon
intervention d'accord et on vous a pas
dit cher lecteur et Cher lectrice vous
viendrez s'il y a du vent oui vous
viendrez à 6h et puis ça démarre à 6h et
demi voilà c'est comme ça bon c'est
pareil quand vous avez un rendez-vous
chez le dentiste en fait on a fait une
société basée sur les horaires toute
notre société aujourd'hui est basée sur
les horaires on va travailler au bureau
à 9 heures qui est du vent ou pas devant
et du soleil ou pas de soleil on prend
le train à 8h qui est le train de
banlieue il vous dit pas s'il y a pas de
vent j'avance pas loin ce qui veut dire
que si on veut garder le même contrat
social que celui qu'on a aujourd'hui la
même promesse vis-à-vis de la population
qui est de rassurer un service
indépendamment des conditions
extérieures qui est la société voilà on
va pas vous dire très cher ami vous avez
un accident de bagnole ben écoutez pas
de chance il y a pas de vent donc on
vous coupe la jambe plutôt que de la
réparer d'accord
mais ce qui était ce qu'on faisait dans
l'ancien temps ce qui était ce qu'on
faisait dans l'ancien temps
bien on a donc une nécessité impérieuse
si on veut rester dans un système qui
ressemble à ça de pallier cette
intermittence alors à l'échelle de la
journée je le redis on peut faire des
batteries on a suffisamment de matériaux
pour faire des batteries peut y arriver
c'est pas un problème point qui reste
non résolu c'est à l'échelle de la
saison ou à l'échelle de l'année et donc
ça c'est le deuxième truc aujourd'hui on
sait pas comment faire alors je vais
illustrer avec un exemple historique je
suis un peu long mais pardon l'Allemagne
avait en 2002 100 GW 100 milliards de
watts c'est comme ça qu'on compte la
puissance électrique installée 100 GW de
centrale pilotable dans le pays
en 2022 elle a 130 ou 140 GW d'éolien et
de solaire et en puissance pilotable
tout compris elle a toujours 100 GW
d'accord donc ce qu'on ne constate pas
en Allemagne qui est quand même le pays
qui a mis le plus le plus le paquet en
Europe sur les énergies renouvelables
intermittentes électriques ce qu'on ne
constate pas aujourd'hui c'est la
capacité qu'ils auraient à se défaire
d'une partie du parc pilotable ça veut
donc dire qu'ils ont pas résolu le
problème du stockage puisqu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'en défaire donc il
s'en servent moins ça fait baisser les
émissions de CO2 c'est une très bonne
idée ce qu'ils ont fait pour faire
baisser les émissions de CO2 s'ils
avaient gardé leur nucléaire effet
baisser le charbon ça aurait été une
encore meilleure idée mais c'est une
très bonne idée pour faire baisser les
émissions de CO2 là où il y a des
centres donc si les Polonais mettent
plein d'éoliennes chez eux c'est une
très bonne idée
voir si on en met chez nous pour en
fournir du courant au Polonais on peut
le discuter éventuellement un truc qui
peut se débattre
mais par contre aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas se débarrasser totalement de la
centrale à charbon totalement de la
centrale à gaz ou totalement de la
centrale hydraulique pour pallier
l'intermittence de ces mots là voilà
c'est c'est ça le truc donc la question
qu'il faut qu'on se pose c'est est-ce
qu'on accepte après on a peut-être pas
d'alternative donc c'est un mais est-ce
qu'on accepte de foncer dans cette
direction sachant que ce truc là ne sera
peut-être pas résolu et à ce moment
comment est-ce qu'on organise la société
de telle sorte que on retrouve
acceptable le fait que Ben les
opérations du genou elles sont peut-être
pas possible H24 et que il faut choisir
le bon moment où on a besoin de se faire
opérer voilà c'est ce qui est une forme
de gestion par la pénurie c'est ce que
j'appelais la pauvreté tout à l'heure
puisque c'est un truc voilà sauf si on
arrive à le désirer voilà c'est pour ça
que les deux sont très imbriqués pour
moi
et que en tout cas l'idée naïf que on va
avoir exactement la même qualité de
service aujourd'hui dans un réseau
électrique avec que des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires dans un monde qui se
démondialise parce que j'insiste on va
avoir ça avec moins de pétrole moins de
pétrole c'est moins de marine marchande
et la capacité de la marine marchande
quand elle était à la voile c'est le 50e
ou le centième de sa capacité actuelle
d'accord donc et sans marine marchande
elle est panneaux solaires viennent plus
de Chine et les éoliennes viennent plus
de Chine d'accord et les métaux sont pas
chez nous donc c'est ça le sujet et le
Sud tout ça c'est un sujet d'orthographe
voilà aujourd'hui j'insiste sur le fait
que
je pense qu'on se coupa assez fortement
la boîte pour voir comment tout ça
pourrait s'organiser ou pas
merci c'était un premier focus le
deuxième en symétrique justement
toujours sur la notion de handicap
qu'elle serait ceux qui pèsent sur une
perpétuation de la forte pénétration du
nucléaire alors est-ce que ce serait un
problème générique sur le parc comme
celui des soudures est-ce que ce serait
une surcomplexité par exemple du modèle
EPR à construire est-ce que ce serait la
gestion des déchets un manque d'eau pour
le refroidissement des centrales ou
alors là aussi l'acceptation sociétale
encore une fois du risque d'accident
majeur en cas de séisme ou d'autres
causes je vous demande une réponse un
tout petit peu plus courte que la
précédente les handicaps de nucléaire ne
sont pas dans les risques du nucléaire
pour faire une réponse très courte ils
sont dans le fait que autant dans les
EnR vous avez une barrière de matériaux
dans le nucléaire vous avez une barrière
de compétences c'est ça le c'est ça la
barrière du nucléaire et une barrière de
capitaux ça ça va vous intéresser
puisque vous aimez l'économie il faut
savoir que aujourd'hui le coût d'un
mégawatt-heure nucléaire et au premier
ordre essentiellement dépendant du coût
du capital
pour un réacteur qui va coûter 10
milliards à construire 10 milliards à
construire entre un coût du capital à 2%
et un coût du capital à 10% la
différence c'est 90 milliards de frais
financiers sur la durée de vie du
réacteur
90 milliards donc en fait un nucléaire
privé est un nucléaire cher donc je fais
partie des gens qui disent que le
nucléaire a rien à faire dans le secteur
privé
un nucléaire moins cher voilà donc mais
dans les inconvénients donc il y a une
barrière de compétences et ou une
barrière de mentalité parce que dire
qu'on va mettre le nucléaire dans le
privé c'est une barrière de mentalité
c'est pas une barrière physique ça ne
dépend que de la convention qu'on a
envie de se donner
il y a une barrière de compétence parce
que c'est un réacteur c'est un gros
bousin compliqué donc moi je suis pas
capable de le faire vous n'êtes pas
capable de le faire il faut trouver des
gens capables de le faire et des gens
capables de le faire il faut 10 ans pour
faire un bon soudeur industriel qu'il
fasse une raffinerie ou un réacteur
nucléaire du reste donc voilà donc il
faut c'est quelque chose qui demande qui
demande du temps c'est ça le principal
handicap du nucléaire dans les handicaps
qu'on lui prête souvent on importe le
radium mais j'insiste on va importer
tous les métaux des éoliennes et tous
les métaux des panneaux solaires et on
va en apporter beaucoup plus en quantité
donc c'est pas parce que on n'a pas de
nucléaire qu'on a pas d'importation et
aujourd'hui on apporte tous les
smartphones et j'ai pas l'impression que
ça vous empêche d'en acheter
la deuxième chose en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire c'est les accidents il faut
savoir que le plus grave accident
industriel de tous les temps c'est pas
du tout l'accident de Tchernobyl c'est
l'accident de bopal qui a tué beaucoup
plus de monde
qui était un accident dans une usine
chimique et le plus grave accident d'une
installation de production d'électricité
en Europe en nombre de morts instantanés
ça a pas été Tchernobyl non plus ça a
été la rupture du barrage de vagin
longue-garonne en Italie qui a fait 2500
morts après un glissement de terrain qui
a fait déborder le lac de barrage et qui
a noyé un virage à un village à Laval
le la question de la dangerosité le
défaut générique par exemple qu'on a
trouvé sur les circuits de secours
c'était des circuits de secours alors je
vais vous poser une question imaginons
que vous ayez des mafioso qui vous court
derrière vous êtes dans votre voiture et
on vous annonce que votre voiture il y a
un dispositif de secours qui peut-être
ne va pas fonctionner vous arrêtez la
voiture
donc là ce que je viens de vous donner
comme exemple c'est le fait que on a la
SN telle qu'elle est bigornets
aujourd'hui n'a pas le mandat d'arbitrer
entre le risque de continuer
l'exploitation et le risque d'arrêter
l'exploitation c'est pas son job son job
c'est le risque si je continue
l'exploitation point barre le fait que
si on arrête l'exploitation on peut
faire mourir plein de gens parce qu'il y
a pas assez d'électricité c'est pas son
problème c'est absolument pas son
problème donc
c'est je dis pas qu'il c'est des gens
malfaisants c'est juste pas dans son
mandat d'accord et comme je disais tout
à l'heure on va devoir arbitrer les
risques à l'avenir donc là une question
par exemple qu'aujourd'hui personne ne
se pose c'est dans quelle mesure est-ce
qu'il serait pertinent de prendre un peu
plus de risques sur la filière nucléaire
un peu plus c'est peut-être pas votre
envie mais un peu plus pour en éviter
beaucoup plus à côté des risques
environnementaux et des risques sociaux
parce que si un défaut de production
électrique
fait que on doit gérer par la pauvreté
quelque chose qu'on aurait pu gérer par
l'électrification comment vous
quantifier cette comment vous faites
cette arbitrage des risques
aujourd'hui il est pas fait du tout et
ça renvoie du reste à la question
derrière la question non mais c'est la
question du débat démocratique
d'ailleurs on peut avoir un débat
démocratique que sur les choses qu'on
connaît d'accord et ces trucs là
aujourd'hui par exemple c'est des choses
qui sont pas explorées
je laisse la parole à Camille Dorival
pour la dernière partie avant les
questions de la salle à propos de ce
qu'on a appelé peut-être un peu
pompeusement la démocratie des choix
techniques mais Camille va nous éclairer
un peu sur ce qu'on a voulu mettre dans
cette partie là
oui alors
effectivement c'est la question du choix
des solutions techniques et de la place
qui est laissée aux citoyens dans ses
choix on constate un décalage assez
important entre les aspirations qui
peuvent être exprimées par les citoyens
et puis les actions qui sont mises en
oeuvre par leur représentants la
meilleure illustration c'est évidemment
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
puisque en juin 2020 les citoyens qui
avaient été engagés dans cette
convention on fait une série de
propositions pour réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre forcé de
constater que la plupart d'entre elles
n'ont pas été reprises ni par la loi ni
par la réglementation il y aurait
d'autres exemples à donner comme ça mais
à votre avis est-ce que la question des
modes de production de l'énergie c'est
la plus pertinente à poser de prime
abord aux citoyens ou est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas d'abord se poser la
question du type de société que ce moyen
que ces moyens de production serviraient
ça revient à ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est est-ce que on souhaite
collectivement aller vers une société
plus frugale ou une société plus
technologique
alors malheureusement on arrive dans ma
vision du monde on n'arrive pas à
dissocier les deux c'est bien le
problème alors je vais commencer par
citer
enfin pas recycler un papier très
intéressant que j'avais lu je crois que
c'est de sylvestruette qui avait fait
remarquer l'énorme différence entre le
monde dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui et le monde il y a deux
siècles et alors il disait il y a deux
siècles tout un chacun pouvait par le
simple regard comprendre les techniques
qui étaient en vigueur à l'époque vous
rentrez dans un moulin vous comprenez ce
que c'est qu'un engrenage vous comprenez
ce que c'est que une des multiplications
il y a un petit pignon qui entraîne une
grande roue comprenez que ça fait
tourner la grande roue plus lentement
que le petit pignon et que par contre ça
met plus de couple enfin vous comprenez
que la force de l'eau fait tourner la
roue à eau parce que la force du vent
fait tourner les moulins etc enfin donc
en fait l'honnête femme et l'honnête
homme de l'époque pouvaient par le
simple regard comprendre la
quasi-totalité des techniques qui
étaient utilisées aujourd'hui c'est
l'exact inverse vous et moi par notre
regard on ne peut absolument rien
comprendre et je regarde ce micro je
sais pas comment il fonctionne je
regarde cette caméra j'ai pas comment
elle fonctionne alors si j'ai une vague
idée de la manière dont fonctionne la
pendule que j'ai en face de moi et qui
me dit que je suis toujours trop long
mais si j'allais
en plus elle est parleur et ça je sais
mais à l'avance quand même donc elle me
donne quand même le temps que j'ai parlé
depuis le début et
donc je sais que là-dedans il y a des
ressorts des tourbillons des machins des
bidules si ça se trouve chez de
l'électronique en fait je dis n'importe
quoi et à ce moment j'étais de nouveau
pas comment ça fonctionne je sais pas si
ici il y a une seule personne qui est
capable de démonter toutes les pièces du
moteur de sa voiture pour les gens qui
ont une voiture et je ne sais pas si ici
il y a une seule personne qui comprend
bien comment fonctionne un train quand
on monte dedans donc en fait et votre
smartphone évidemment vous comprenez pas
comment il marche et moi non plus du
reste donc aujourd'hui il y a plus une
seule technique plus une seule dont nous
dépendons au quotidien au quotidien
est-ce que vous savez comment fonctionne
la machine qui a fabriqué votre vêtement
non moi non plus le restaurant donc il y
a pas une seule technique dont on dont
on dépend au quotidien
en premier ordre qui ne soit accessible
à tout un chacun elles sont toujours
accessibles uniquement aux gens qui
travaillent dans le secteur et qu'il est
maîtrise et encore les experts alors
appelons les comme ça appelons les comme
ça on peut les appeler des experts des
sachants des oui mais est-ce que vous
appelleriez expert un ouvrier qui pilote
une ligne de production de vaccin
voyez il y a une petite connotation dans
le mot expert en attendant le sol qui
s'est à peu près comment fonctionne sa
ligne de production c'est lui bon donc
on a des spécialistes je préférerais
dire voilà probablement que le mot est
mieux est mieux choisi on est dans un
monde de spécialiste vu que ça posait
interconnecté et aucun d'entre nous n'a
aujourd'hui la capacité à disposer d'une
vision totale sur l'ensemble des
composantes qui sont nécessaires à ce
que le monde fonctionne il y a pas de
grand architecte qui sait tout partout
tout le temps
ça marche pas du coup c'est très
difficile d'organiser des débats qu'on
appelle comme on veut citoyen
démocratique etc
parce que l'étape numéro un qui est tout
simplement le partage de la connaissance
sur le monde tel qu'il est c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est vachement
compliqué comme dirait l'autre à
organiser c'est très très difficile et
en fait dans les dans les dialogues j'ai
envie de dire dessous qu'il y a donc
avant même qu'on soit pas d'accord
philosophiquement
sont les dialogues les pierres dialogues
de sourds c'est quand on n'arrive pas à
se mettre d'accord sur les faits
et à ce moment on n'arrive pas à
dépasser cette étape c'est très clair
alors pourquoi est-ce que j'arrive pas à
distinguer l'énergie des modes de vie
parce que
si vous m'avez un peu lu vous savez que
les modes de vie qu'on a aujourd'hui
sont le résultat de l'abondance
énergétique car l'abondance énergétique
qui habille les machines au travail à
notre place en nous créant un
exosquelette surpuissant à créer le
temps qu'on a pour des batteries ici
qu'on n'aurait pas eu à deux siècles il
y a deux siècles on aurait tous été
exténués après avoir ramassé des patates
Charriers des pierres etc déjà il y
aurait pas eu de lumière il y aurait pas
eu de lampes avec un incandescence donc
voilà on aura peut-être pas eu les
moyens de se payer toutes les toutes les
chandelles et les bougies qu'il fallait
pour éclairer cette pièce voilà donc en
fait on serait pas vrai donc vous voyez
or aujourd'hui vous considérez que
d'aller écouter un débat ça fait partie
de votre mode de vie
dans un monde où il y avait pas de
machine et pas d'énergie il y avait pas
de mondialisation les gens avaient une
chemise ou deux chemises leurs vies
durant ils avaient pas de congés payés
ils avaient pas de retraite ils avaient
pas d'études longues il y avait pas
d'emploi dans le tertiaire il y avait
pas d'égalité entre les droits des
hommes et des femmes
parce que vous auriez eu un enfant sur
pour ceux qui seraient mort en couche et
vous auriez passé votre temps à être
enceinte et à l'été enfin je suis un peu
cash mais c'est pour dire j'ai pas si
vous vous rendez compte de ce que
l'énergie nous a amené c'est juste
hallucinant quoi bon donc je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui dissocier et c'est bien mon
drame et c'est bien le problème je ne
sais pas dissocier aujourd'hui le débat
sur l'énergie du débat sur les modes de
vie je ne sais pas faire ça
pose d'énormes problèmes parce que on
voit bien que tous les débats qu'on
essaye d'organiser sur le sujet Quel que
soit les intentions qu'on prête bonne ou
mauvaises aux organisateurs du débat
reviennent à essayer d'attraper
l'éléphant par un bout là et puis on
c'est toujours qu'un bout quoi vachement
difficile de lui attraper en même temps
les pattes la trompe et les oreilles
quoi on y arrive pas
donc cette fin si c'est une réponse qui
vous satisfait beaucoup mais comme
disait l'autre c'est la mienne c'est
encore une fois très difficile alors on
peut essayer d'avoir des choses qui
améliorent par exemple la convention
citoyenne pour le climat on a amélioré
en donnant une étape de formation sur le
climat mais il y avait pas d'étape de
formation sur les processus industriels
modernes il y avait pas d'étapes de
formation sur la mondialisation il n'y
avait pas d'étapes de formation sur les
matières qui sont nécessaires il y avait
donc il y avait quelques étapes mais
c'est juste impensable de les faire
toutes
je sais pas s'il y a eu vraiment une
étape de discussion un peu philosophique
sur les choix de mode de vie aussi c'est
très difficile encore une fois de
dissocier les deux c'est très difficile
de dissocier les deux est-ce que la
notion du partage a toujours le même
sens si on doit partager sa perceuse ou
si on doit partager sa chambre à coucher
donc on peut faire un grand débat sur le
partage mais tant qu'on n'a pas dit si
il s'agissait de sa chambre à coucher ou
s'il s'agissait de sa perceuse
on n'est pas on a rien dit quoi vous
comprenez c'est
alors du coup si on vous suit comment on
résout le problème du choix démocratique
et comment on fait participer les
citoyens au choix de société qui sont
devant nous ce que j'ai trouvé de moins
mal aujourd'hui comme de moins mauvais
on va dire comme processus c'est ce
qu'on essaye de mettre en oeuvre au sein
du chiffre project c'est à dire des gens
qui ne sont peut-être pas des experts
essayent d'être un peu des spécialistes
et essaye de regarder de façon un peu
large
jouer au Lego
essaye de d'imaginer des constructions
et les donne comme boîte à café à
d'autres en leur disant voilà on a pensé
à ça vous en pensez quoi
donc ça fait économiser du temps aux
gens parce qu'on leur propose une
construction déjà prête et il faut
évidemment faire ça dans l'esprit que
les gens vous disent ben non on n'est
pas d'accord là vous avez raté une
marche on est d'accord pour ceci mais
pas pour cela etc c'est exactement comme
ça qu'on a essayé de faire les toutes
les propositions qu'on a faites donc en
gros on essaye on commence par faire un
petit débroussaillage en chambre puis
ensuite on travaille avec des gens d'un
secteur d'un usage d'un etc puis on
essaye d'avancer ensemble pour imaginer
comment comment ça pourrait se présenter
puis on finit par boucler avec le reste
en disant est-ce que notre truc il
flotte toujours dans un monde dans
lequel en même temps tout le reste est
bouge évolue
et puis une fois qu'on a quelque chose
qui nous paraît correspondre à peu près
à ce genre de critères ce qui sont les
nôtres encore une fois à ce moment on
essaye de les mettre en débat et donc
d'essayer d'en discuter avec des gens à
droite à gauche voilà c'est ce qu'on a
trouvé de moins mauvais comme méthode je
sais pas si c'est merveilleux si ça
permet de répondre et de cocher toutes
les cases c'est un peu comme ça qu'on
essaye de qu'on essaie de fonctionner
quand vous avez des consultations sur
des constructions qui s'agisse de la
Commission européenne qui met des trucs
en consultation qui met etc on s'en
approche un peu à la limite de ce genre
de processus c'est que ça s'adresse
qu'il y a des gens qui ont du temps
oui est-ce que des compétences est-ce
que est-ce que du coup ça invalide
beaucoup de ce que vous leur demandez
je vais prendre un exemple quand vous
travaillez sur le l'avenir de
l'agriculture
bon vous dites bah voilà on a réfléchi à
une agriculture avec un cahier des
charges qui est on essaie d'avoir
beaucoup moins d'engrais qu'aujourd'hui
on essaye d'avoir beaucoup moins de
phytosanitaires du coup on a des
rendements végétaux qui baissent du coup
ça veut dire que on a moins d'aliments
pour le bétail donc du coup ça veut dire
qu'on mange moins de viande on garde
plutôt les vaches aux pâturages
laitières on arrête les Rasses avions et
on arrête les trucs qui sont donc en
fait on met des à la place des
limousines on met des
montbéliardes voilà
il faudra qu'on fasse du fromage dans ce
coin là et puis
voilà comment on essaye d'organiser les
circuits de distribution il faut qu'on
remette de la valeur ajoutée plus près
des exploitations agricoles il faut que
enfin bon bref et puis après tout le
monde mange donc à un moment et puis
tout le monde a vu là là on est encore
loin de la technique d'une certaine
manière c'est un sujet facile tout le
monde sait ce que c'est qu'une vache et
tout le monde sait ce que c'est qu'un
épi de blé en fait bon même si il y a
des gamins suisses qui dessinent les
vaches violettes parce que ils ont tout
ce qu'ils ont vu c'est les emballages de
chocolat Milka mais
moquez-vous on est devenu une population
urbain déconnectée de ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur ce qui est un des problèmes
du reste et donc
on leur dit bah voilà
comment se présenterait un paysage
alternatif qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
Jean arrive à comprendre même sans
comprendre dans le détail comment
fonctionne une ligne de vaccin on peut
avoir un débat sur si on a moins
d'énergie et moins de machines et qu'on
produit moins de vaccins comment est-ce
qu'on les répartit
d'accord
est-ce que on vaccine plutôt les vieux
ou plutôt les jeunes
c'est des alors ça va être que des
débats difficiles il faut bien
comprendre qu'on sort de l'air des
débats faciles c'est c'est voilà
du reste tout à l'heure dans ma
présentation Mehdi j'ai fait l'unanimité
de la gauche à la droite je fais aussi
des inédité contre moi de temps en temps
de la gauche à la droite
parce que
j'essaye enfin j'essaie mais j'essaye de
le faire pour que les gens réfléchissent
de poser des questions un peu dures si
on a beaucoup moins de disponibilité
dans l'appareil de soins à qui on les
donne en premier
d'accord
bon c'est pas une question simple non
c'est pas une question simple mais c'est
une question qui va se poser
si on a beaucoup moins de vols en avion
comment est-ce qu'on répartis des trucs
d'accord par les prix ou par les
quantités
alors là l'exercice que j'ai fait c'est
tout le monde a le même droit à voler
donc les gens dans cette salle les
Somaliens les Togolais les Turcs et les
Indiens d'accord ça fait 6 peut-être
pour nous alors à ce moment ça veut dire
que vous faites deux pour les Somaliens
j'ai ok moi pas de problème avec ça
c'est votre choix mais voilà mais mon
hypothèse de départ c'était que tout le
monde avait le même partout sur terre
la règle de trois je l'ai publié donc
voilà c'est c'est pas c'est pas une
proposition pour demain matin je sais
très bien que c'est totalement
irréaliste pour demain matin c'était un
ordre de grandeur pour frapper les
esprits c'est bien marché
puisque je me suis implicitement fait
traiter de nazis par Luc Ferry
je ne sais je ne sais pas si un
compliment c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
plusieurs fois donc
mais c'est fait pour frapper les esprits
parce que encore une fois nous allons au
devant de débat difficile
malheureusement et je pense que plus on
les c'est très lié avec ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur le fait que l'avenir
ne sera pas sans risque et qu'on va
devoir arbitrer entre les risques et
arbitrer et prendre des décisions voilà
donc comment est-ce qu'on fait pour
impliquer le collectif dans des choix
difficiles il y a peut-être aussi des
méthodes qui restent à inventer
aujourd'hui qu'on a voilà on n'est pas
encore tout à fait au bout de ce qui
reste à faire et je vais finir en disant
pour le moment les débats on sait les
faire parce que on a des outils de
communication
si demain on a plus de téléphone comment
on fait les débats d'accord donc vous
voyez bon c'est pas pour demain matin
mais c'est voilà c'est pour comprendre
que même ça
est un sujet
juste peut-être pour préciser un peu
votre pensée avant qu'on passe la parole
à la salle est-ce que ça veut dire ce
que vous dites que ça invalide toute
solution démocratique de type convention
citoyenne consultation citoyenne
référendum etc alors j'ai trouvé que
l'exemplaire alors référendum je peux
réservé parce que vous savez quand on
pose un référendum dans ce pays en
général on répond à la personne qui a
posé la question beaucoup plus qu'on ne
répond à la question
les Suisses sont une maturité qui est
plus importante que la nôtre donc ils
savent poser et puis des référendums ils
ont tous les mois donc c'est un peu
voilà bon
sur par contre la convention citoyenne
moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un exercice
super intéressant
qui avait été gâché parce que la
promesse initiale était une promesse
irréaliste alors ce que j'ai trouvé
super intéressant dans la convention
citoyenne c'est que vous prenez 150
personnes qui ne se connaissent pas
j'insiste qui ne se connaissent pas qui
sont raisonnablement représentatifs de
la population proche du raisonnablement
parce que dans les premiers 150 qu'on
avait tirés au sort était tout à fait
représentatifs et là dedans il y en a 30
qu'on dit nous on veut pas y aller
d'accord donc on en a tiré 30
supplémentaires qu'on dit nous on veut
bien y aller donc il y a un tout petit
peu un tout petit biais de sélection
mais enfin 30 sur 150 c'est pas un
énorme biais de sélection
donc 150 personnes qui se connaissent
pas qui sont représentatives de la
population française vous les mettez
dans une position dans lesquelles vous
les traitez comme des adultes c'est à
vous leur dites vous allez décider des
contraintes que vous allez choisir de
vous puisque vous faites partie de la
société française s'imposer
c'est comme ça qu'on leur dit d'accord
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse dites
nous ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse c'est
quand ils disent il faut qu'on roule à
110 c'est y compris eux d'accord est-ce
que avant la convention un sondage fait
auprès des mêmes qui ne se connaissait
pas on leur aurait demandé à ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour rouler à 110 je pense
qu'il y en a plein que je vous aurais
dit non donc ce que montre cet exercice
moi je trouve de très intéressant c'est
la force du collectif la force de la
mise en responsabilité et aussi la force
de l'information parce que avant de les
faire réfléchir on les a informé donc je
trouve que c'est un exercice qui est
super intéressant moi je pense que par
exemple dans les exécutifs locaux
ça c'est quelque chose qui pourrait être
extrêmement intéressant pour prendre
pour prendre plein de décisions et même
même national enfin je veux dire et là
où Macron a dit à rater son coup c'est
quand il a dit je reprendrai sans filtre
c'est une connerie énorme fallait
surtout pas dire ça il fallait dire je
m'engage à passer autant de temps à
regarder ce qui a été produit que les
gens ont passé de temps à le produire
d'accord parce que après
même animée de la meilleure intention du
monde il peut y avoir des trucs qui sont
je sais pas il y a un obstacle juridique
par exemple alors implémentation
vous dites tiens il faudrait s'occuper
de l'agriculture comme ça rapidement de
choses il y a une politique agricole
commune qui fait que on peut pas bon ben
à ce moment vous dites votre truc je
prends l'idée
mais demain matin on peut pas
donc il fallait juste s'engager à être
sérieux sur l'examen des propositions
qui avaient été faites dire je reprends
sans filtre ça c'est évident que ça
allait partir dans le décor mais par
contre j'ai trouvé moi l'exercice
extrêmement intéressant donc est-ce que
mes gens ont dû passer du temps ils ont
dû venir les week-ends ce qui veut dire
que il a fallu mettre en place un
système pour garder les enfants pour
ceux qui en ont parce que dans une
population représentative il y a
quelques personnes qui ont lieu des
farfelues d'avoir des enfants
donc enfin voilà donc
pour ceux qui bossent le week-end parce
qu'il y en avait peut-être quelques-uns
il a fallu qu'ils acceptent enfin que
leur employeur accepte qu'il se fasse
portait pas enfin voilà
mais mais ça montre bien que quand des
gens pas informés au départ acceptent de
passer du temps sur un sujet et qu'on
les met dans une position qui est une
position de mise en responsabilité
collective il peut se passer des trucs
très intéressants voilà moi je trouve
que c'est ça voilà donc je suis pas du
tout en train de dire que c'est mort
d'abord c'est mort d'avance par contre
il faut avoir des cahiers des charges
qui souhaitent nobles
et il faut bien avoir conscience du fait
que le débat démocratique ça demande du
temps
je vais vous donner un autre exemple qui
est la manière dont cette tenue le débat
sur les déchets nucléaires en Suède
le débat sur les déchets nucléaires en
Suède ça a été 20 000 débats d'arrière
cuisine c'était 20 000 débats à 20
personnes c'est comme ça qu'ils ont fait
donc ça a pris un temps absolument
considérable
voilà on peut pas faire ça surtout donc
il faut bien choisir les grands sujets
sur lesquels on les fait
merci beaucoup on arrive à la fin de la
troisième séquence et du privilège qu'on
a eu de pouvoir vous poser en direct les
questions maintenant la salle peut se
joindre à nous
je vous rappelle qu'on essaye de faire
des questions courtes et puis Jean-Marc
s'engage à faire des réponses courtes
la parole circule
je vais prendre un homme une femme je
vous préviens commence par une femme
donc on commence par une femme après ça
sera un homme etc très bonne initiative
ça change j'ai deux questions mais très
courte
moi je m'occupe d'un réseau de Scop
voilà donc la démocratie effectivement
ça prend du temps
on a des entreprises qui sont hyper
volontaristes
qu'est-ce que vous leur donneriez comme
conseil simple parce que franchement
dans la jungle de tout ce qui est
proposé on évoqué les scénarios Adem etc
en fait ça reste quand même très
compliqué pour les entreprises
elles-mêmes et celles qui les
accompagnent donc ça c'est ma première
question la deuxième c'est par rapport à
l'approche citoyenne
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous ce que
vous évoquez par rapport à le fait
l'importance en tout cas de tendre vers
un peu
spécialité pour pouvoir participer aux
solutions mais du coup ça me paraît un
peu contradictoire par rapport à ce que
vous
sur le le désir à faire enfin faire
émerger en tout cas pour la sobriété ce
sur quoi je suis entièrement d'accord
sur en tout cas l'idée de de désir et on
voit bien que dans les démarches
citoyennes si un truc qui marche bien
c'est effectivement d'avoir le sentiment
qu'on prend en compte son avis du coup
ça j'ai une petite j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a une petite contradiction là
alors ah je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris
ce que vous entendez par contradiction
ce qui est sûr c'est que l'acceptation
de la contrainte est toujours beaucoup
plus forte quand on a l'impression qu'on
a construit cette contrainte pour une
bonne raison donc en fait c'est une
forme d'autodiscipline
je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris la
question sur le désert ça vous dites en
fait le désir si il vient par exemple
d'une mode il est nécessairement imposé
de l'extérieur c'est ça c'est ça votre
sujet ou c'est autre chose
l'un des objectifs ça serait de
travailler plutôt sur le désir de
consommer moins oui et du coup là c'est
vrai que dans les concertations dans les
démarches citoyennes ce qui ce qui fait
le désir en tout cas c'est de pouvoir
porter des idées qui risquent d'être
retenu
voyez et quand vous dites que
enfin voilà
contribuer en tout cas à des à des
solutions il faut quand même être un peu
spécialiste sinon ça sert à rien quoi en
gros je trouve qu'il y a une petite
contradiction comment on pourrait faire
en sorte en tout cas que voilà on prenne
en compte la parole en fait moi je
trouve que les démarches de concertation
apportent à porte vraiment ce plus quoi
dans la nuit solution d'une manière
générale dans l'émergence du désir il y
a souvent quelque chose de collectif
parce que on est des animaux sociaux
du reste une des réticences au
changement souvent c'est de se couper
d'un cercle de relation famille
relation amoureuse collègues etc qu'on a
bâti en ne tenant pas compte d'un
élément nouveau et quand on met
l'élément nouveau qui nous oblige à
changer de comportement un des prix
qu'on est qu'on n'a pas envie de payer
c'est le fait de se couper d'un tissu de
relation de etc c'est l'éternel exemple
de ce qu'on va servir au repas du
dimanche c'est l'éternel exemples du
moyen de transport utilisé pour partir
en vacances etc
mais mais je suis pas sûr moi de voir
une contradiction entre le fait que on
est des démarches collectives et le fait
que il y a une émergence du désir en
face
je suis pas sûr de voir pourquoi il y a
une contradiction je je pense pas que je
pense pas qu'il y en ait
fondamentalement une c'était peut-être
parce que j'ai pris deux angles de vue
sur
alors sur les SCOP
en fait les SCOP du point de vue de la
réponse que je vais faire sont pas
différents de tout autre entreprise
j'imagine qu'il s'agit pas de
multinationales donc il imagine qu'il
s'agit de petite boîte et en fait dans
une petite boîte quel que soit sa forme
juridique il y a un problème qui est le
temps c'est à dire la bande passante de
l'équipe dirigeante
parce que même dans une SCOP il y a une
équipe dirigeante et qui est
qui est en général
un vrai sujet pour s'imprégner d'un
problème nouveau et revisité tout ce qui
fait une entreprise les gens qui
travaillent les compétences qu'ils ont
là où l'entreprise est située les
clients qu'elle sert les process de
production qu'elle a les fournisseurs
avec lesquels elle travaille le cadre
réglementaire dans lequel elle se situe
etc et en fait comme dans ma vision
historique du monde l'énergie a changé
tout ça c'est à dire l'aire des machines
a changé tout ça en fait il faut
regarder tout ça à la fois et
effectivement on est pris de vertige si
je prends le truc par quel bout
alors ça c'est peut-être mon travers de
consultant mais je pense que c'est très
très difficile pour des gens comme ça
d'y arriver seul extrêmement difficile
donc ou bien ils ont le temps et les
moyens économiques de s'adoudre une aide
extérieure qui aujourd'hui en plus sont
pas très nombreuses parce que des gens
qui sont bigorés avec ce que je viens de
vous dire là qui résonne system etc et
pas tant que ça et ils le font ou bien
ils ont pas la possibilité pas cette
possibilité et ce que je connais de
moins mauvais qui s'en approche c'est de
commencer à discuter avec des gens qui
ont le même problème que donc c'est tous
les cercles qui réunissent des
dirigeants de petites entreprises donc
ça commence ça demande quand même un peu
du temps mais qui font périodiquement
des réunions qui qui essayent de
discuter de la façon dont eux ont pris
le problème etc et là dans ce genre de
cercle souvent c'est plus facile de
faire venir un intervenant à un moment
qui va un peu secouer tout le monde et
qui va qui va permettre aux gens de
commencer à réfléchir voilà mais mais
c'est j'ai envie de dire c'est c'est le
truc le plus élémentaire en général
c'est de parler du problème avec
d'autres personnes parce que elles
auront éventuellement pensé à quelque
chose une lecture regardez un truc voilà
ça mais quand on a besoin d'un nouvel
angle de vue c'est c'est compliqué de le
trouver en soi quand on n'a pas beaucoup
de temps
merci beaucoup
bonsoir merci beaucoup vous parlez tout
à l'heure de l'arbitrage entre la sûreté
nucléaire et le risque de baisse de
production des centrales et je vous
propose un autre arbitrage à discuter
sur le risque de jour de baisse de
production et le risque environnemental
en parlant des centrales nucléaires au
bord de fleuve bon climatique où les
températures de fleuve vont augmenter et
le débit va à l'inverse plutôt diminué
ce qui pose un problème du coup pour les
refroidissements quand on vous parle de
sujet en interview moi de ce que j'ai
revenu de vos réponses c'est que vous
répondez que ce n'est pas risque pas
c'est une nucléaire puisque sûreté
nucléaire pardon parce qu'on peut
baisser la production sauf que du coup
cette baisse de production comme vous
l'avez dit avant pose un problème et du
coup dans un monde où on peut avoir une
canicule généraliste toute la France et
donc tous les centrales qui sont amenés
à baisser leurs production est-ce que
c'est pas un souci d'autant qu'on voit
que dans les années précédentes en fait
il y a eu plusieurs cas de centrales qui
dépassent les normes via des arrêtés
préfectoraux de rejet donc qu'est-ce que
vous avez alors la le risque que vous
évoquez ne concerne que les centrales
qui sont en bord de rivière il y a une
partie des centrales françaises qui sont
en bord de mer donc celle-là elles sont
pas concernées et par ailleurs ça
concerne toutes les centrales thermiques
qui sont en bord de rivière le risque
existe aussi pour la face exactement le
même problème pour les centrales à
charbon et cetera
c'est effectivement pas un risque de
sûreté c'est à dire que c'est pas un
truc qui est susceptible de déclencher
un accident c'est un risque de baisse de
la production parce que en fait si vous
avez moins de alors aujourd'hui le
facteur limitant c'est par la quantité
d'eau dans le fleuve c'est la
température de rejet de l'eau qu'on
prélève d'accord donc c'est ça qui force
à baisser la production
pour pas pour pas gêner les écosystèmes
à Laval du rejet de l'eau
vous avez
souvent en France aujourd'hui enfin
actuellement en France la consommation
d'électricité l'été est beaucoup plus
faible que la consommation d'électricité
l'hiver vous avez quasiment un facteur 2
entre les deux et c'est à cause de ça
que l'essentiel du temps les arrêts de
tranches se font quand le covid vient
pas mettre le pastis là-dedans se font
l'été
donc le fait d'avoir moins d'électricité
l'été aujourd'hui c'est pas un problème
crucial le jour où tout le monde sera
climatisé on en reparlera mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas un premier
peut-être que justement il faut éviter
que tout le monde se climatise et
réfléchir à d'autres solutions
mais mais pour le moment c'est pas un
problème c'est pas un problème majeur
il y a un certain nombre de dispositifs
techniques qui peuvent permettre de soit
de traiter le problème soit de le
baisser par exemple dans les centrales
qui sont en bord de fleuve toutes n'ont
pas des tours de refroidissement qui
permettent de prélever beaucoup moins
d'eau pour refroidir la centrale parce
que en fait vous allez refroidir la
centrale en évaporant de l'eau au lieu
de juste la réchauffer et la remettre et
quand vous évaporez de l'eau vous
utilisez vous consommez beaucoup plus de
chaleur c'est voilà donc on peut
rajouter des aéros réfrigérants sur
certaines centrales la plus grosse
centrale aux États-Unis ça c'est une
anecdote que vous connaissez peut-être
je vais le dire aux autres elle est au
vrai sens du terme dans la merde parce
que en fait elle se refroidit avec les
eaux de les eaux usées de la ville de
Félix d'accord comme ça qu'elle soit
refroidie
donc voilà donc il y a un certain nombre
de dispositifs techniques qui
éventuellement pour être mis en oeuvre
pour que ce truc là ce problème là soit
minimisé
le truc ultime s'il y a plus d'eau du
tout dans le fleuve mais enfin avant
qu'il y ait plus d'eau du tout dans le
Rhône quand même il va se passer un
moment
c'est tout bêtement de l'arrêter et à ce
moment une fois que vous êtes en arrière
froid vous avez besoin d'un débit d'eau
pour garder le réacteur en sûreté qui
est
considérablement plus fait vous avez
besoin de quelques litres à la seconde
donc là c'est enfin vous les trouvez par
un forage dans la nappe s'il faut enfin
c'est pas c'est pas un sujet voilà donc
effectivement il y a un risque de baisse
de production
lié à la disponibilité en eau l'été tout
à fait tout à fait clair
prends une autre question madame
aujourd'hui les quantifié à quelques
pourcents de la production annuelle dans
un scénario de réchauffement
significatif c'est un scénario
alors dans les boîtes à casser il y a
vous avez envisagé un scénario avec
beaucoup de nucléaires il y a pas que
chez nous
est-ce que ça signifie vous avez dit
tout à l'heure à Essen et pas tout à
fait câblé pour arbitrer entre des
risques de court terme et de moyens
termes si je reformule est-ce que ça
veut dire que on va disséminer partout
sur la planète du nucléaire pour
arbitrer entre des risques de court
terme et de moyens termes en espérant
que personne ira faire je joue sur la
porridja ou ailleurs
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez les pays
qui ont du nucléaire à peu près 80 alors
j'ai regardé quelques années c'est
toujours toi aujourd'hui 90% du parc
nucléaire actuel se trouve dans des pays
pardon
90% des centrales à charbon actuel
c'était ça mon calcul se trouve dans des
pays qui ont déjà du nucléaire
aujourd'hui donc en fait il y a pas
besoin de sortir des pays qui ont déjà
du nucléaire aujourd'hui pour traiter
l'essentiel du problème du charbon
existant parce qu'en fait c'est ça le
sujet le nucléaire qu'est ce que ça
traite sa traite le charbon existant ça
permet d'avoir toujours de l'électricité
en remplaçant des combustibles fossiles
c'est ça c'est ça le c'est ça le sujet
oui alors je fais partie des tristes
cirques qui pensent qu'on y arrivera
jamais c'est à dire que les 1,2
milliards de voitures qu'on a dans le
monde plus et 2200 gigawatts de
centrales à charbon qu'on a dans le
monde de toute façon tout ça sera pas
décarboné dans les 30 ans qui viennent
et donc on va se prendre des baffes
c'est absolument évident une partie va
se résoudre par des craquements dans le
système ça c'est bon pas très drôle à
dire mais je pense que malheureusement
on a trop attendu pour que aujourd'hui
ça se gère partout dans la joie et la
bonne humeur
est-ce que dans ce
qu'est ce que j'ai du coup dans ce dans
ce contexte là
un certain nombre de pays sont en train
d'essayer d'en faire la Chine et le pays
qui de loin en construit le plus
aujourd'hui ensuite vous avez les Russes
qui ont un gros carnet de commandes
alors une partie chez eux une bonne
partie à l'étranger
dans les pays occidentaux c'est beaucoup
moins la grande vague elle est passée
dans les années 70-80 90 en France
depuis il y a pas eu grand chose de
significatif
la le fait de recommencer en fait c'est
la question qui a été posée tout à
l'heure le fait de recommencer est un
truc qui est raisonnablement long donc
de toute façon je ne pense pas que on va
voir des centrales nucléaires absolument
partout poussé comme des champignons
demain matin pas ça qui est en train de
se préparer
mais c'est pas nécessairement une bonne
nouvelle parce que je le redis
aujourd'hui
on continue vous savez cette année on va
encore battre un record d'émission de
gaz à effet de serre
donc la réalité de ce qui est en train
de se passer en ce moment c'est que on
continue à être massivement dépendant
des combustibles fossiles y compris dans
la génération électrique
je vous propose comme il est bientôt 20h
et que la fin approche de prendre deux
questions et Jean-Marc vous aurez le
possibilité de répondre
à ces deux en même temps
mais oui merci et moi j'ai bien aimé
votre définition de la sobriété
comme renoncement volontaire à des
services
on réfléchissant et si on fait ça
sérieusement et à grande masse si on
agrège l'ensemble de ces services ça se
traduit par une diminution d'une
grandeur macroéconomique qui s'appelle
PIB
donc vu par les macroéconomistes ça va
s'appeler de la décroissance je pense
que ça n'est pas mais ça va s'appeler de
la décroissance parallèlement tous les
calculs macroéconomiques toute la
politique économique repose sur des
hypothèses de croissance du PIB y
compris le travail qui a été fait par
pizani Ferri et selmafous que vous avez
défendu et a juste titre sur France
Inter repose sur cette cette hypothèse
de maintien de la croissance de cette
indicateur de cet agrec à quel PIB alors
ma question elle est elle est est-ce que
à partir de vos travaux vous avez
commencé à réfléchir ce qui pourrait
être un indicateur alternatif qui
permettrait de faire du calcul
économique parce que derrière tout ça
pour pour transformer tout ça en
politique économique il faut pouvoir
faire du calcul économique qui
permettent justement de sortir de cette
impasse un peu logique entre un PIB qui
agrège des tas de choses on le voit
aujourd'hui à propos du débat sur
l'avion en fait on défend l'avion parce
que ça contribue à la croissance du PIB
et du coup je complète avec ma seconde
question très rapidement merci merci
pour votre intervention ma question
concerne la sobriété son cou et la
temporalité de nos actions notamment
avec l'urgence climatique qui approche
la sobriété coûte relativement cher
c'est des solutions nouvelles à mettre
en place c'est des systèmes nouveaux à
penser c'était des modes de pensée à
changer comment mettre en place cette
sobriété relativement rapidement pour
essayer de pallier au plus vite aux
problèmes auxquels on va se confronter
et essayer de réduire les les dommages
collatéraux
sur la première question je ne pense pas
qu'il soit nécessaire de changer le PIB
je pense qu'il est nécessaire de faire
deux choses la première c'est que ça ne
soit pas un objectif de société
d'accord que non non mais il faut qu'on
arrive à se dire le PIB n'est pas un
objectif de société un objectif de
société c'est en fait ça revient à la
question tout à l'heure c'est le le
genre de climat qu'on a envie d'avoir le
genre d'environnement qu'on a envie
d'avoir le type de logement qu'on a
envie d'avoir tout ça dans la limite des
possibilités physiques qu'on dit etc
ce qui nous manque aujourd'hui c'est la
capacité à gérer la collectivité que le
PIB monte ou descendre c'est ça qu'on
n'a pas aujourd'hui donc on sait gérer
quand ça monte on sait pas géré quand ça
descend
c'est pas une affaire de changer
d'indicateur
c'est une affaire d'arriver à faire en
sorte que la variation
ne soit pas quelque chose
comment dire qui est qui soit un autre
premier point d'attention
alors je sais que dit comme ça c'est
facile parce que si le PIB baisse ça
veut dire que les salaires de tous les
gens dans la salle baisse et comment ça
va avoir bon facile et charges baissent
en même temps ou bien si dans le même
temps on se dit c'est pas très grave
parce que il y avait tel état de machin
que j'achetais finalement j'en ai pas
tellement besoin je vais rater de
l'acheter enfin donc il y a c'est très
difficile
de comment dire
aujourd'hui ce qui nous manque c'est les
réflexions sur les gestion
opérationnelles que ça suppose d'avoir
un PIB qui baisse en fait c'est ça qui
nous manque aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
fait en parika et à force de se dire
c'est une éventualité inenvisageable
vous n'y pensez pas mon gros monsieur
vous n'y pensez pas ma bonne dame en
fait ça va nous arriver alors qu'on est
à poil
c'est à dire que on n'a pas de mode
un peu doux j'ai envie de dire de
gestion de ce truc là alors que
probablement qu'on pourrait avoir des
trucs
au moins au début pas trop douloureux
qui permettrait de s'en accommoder
tout en
tout en mettant pas en péril la
stabilité sociale voilà ce que voilà ce
que je veux dire aujourd'hui on est
quand même dans une construction dans
laquelle avec un PIB en décrue on sait
pas gérer la stabilité sociale bon et en
fait c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
inventer je pense pas que de que de que
de
et j'insiste quand je dis le PIB est pas
un objectif de société j'insiste aussi
parce que vous savez quand vous faites
d'un indicateur l'objectif premier de
vos efforts
il se met vous devenez très malheureux
si l'indicateur va pas dans le bon sens
oui mais du coup ça veut dire qu'il faut
arrêter de faire voilà je ne suis pas
sûr que vous organisiez toute votre vie
en fonction de la vitesse à laquelle
vous courrez parce que si vous faites ça
entre 0 et 30 ans vous êtes très heureux
et à partir de 30 ans vous êtes très
malheureux d'accord bon donc vous
dépatouez pour que ça soit autre chose
que vous allez regarder pas juste ça
vous en tenez probablement compte à un
moment ou un autre mais c'est pas juste
ça que vous allez regarder
en ce qui concerne la façon dont on gère
notre monde je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on arrive à avoir un peu cette vision
tableau de bord qu'on a nous
en tant qu'être humain parce que vous
regardez pas juste la vitesse à laquelle
vous courrez vous regardez la qualité
devant relation amicales la qualité de
vos relations de cœur laquelle c'est
vrai vous regardez tout un tas de trucs
et puis bon et aujourd'hui au niveau
sociétal c'est ça qu'il faudrait qu'on
arrive à faire c'est de passer d'un truc
qui nous obsède à quelque chose qui est
un indicateur parmi 50 et si descend bah
on arrive à gérer quand même c'est ça et
je pense qu'il est urgent de réfléchir à
ce genre de truc parce que j'insiste
comme comme de toute façon ça va nous
arriver
je pense que c'est mieux d'avoir des
idées sur quoi faire plutôt que de ne
pas en avoir du tout
après la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on organise la sobriété
parce que ça demande beaucoup
d'investissements
alors ça demande pas nécessairement
beaucoup d'investissements c'est
l'efficacité qui demande beaucoup
d'investissement c'est-à-dire si vous
voulez électrifier tout le parc de
voiture en gardant des parcs de voiture
en gardant des voitures d'une tonne 2 ou
d'une tonne 5 ça c'est dans la catégorie
efficacité pas du tout dans la catégorie
sobriété dans la catégorie sobriété vous
divisez par 2 le parc de voiture et les
gens fonctionnent avec un parc de
voitures ça ça demande pas beaucoup
d'investissement
absolument mais mais globalement ça va
vous demander moins d'argent d'investir
dans des usines de vélo et dans des
usines de bus pour transporter les gens
que dans des usines de voiture donc et
ça va vous demander moins
d'investissement de faire des pistes
cyclables que de faire des autoroutes
donc globalement
la sobriété elle est pas très
consommatrice d'investissement c'est
l'efficacité qu'il est j'insiste et par
contre elle est très consommatrice de de
consentement
d'accord donc elle est très
consommatrice de temps elle est
consommatrice d'explications
elle est consommatrice de pédagogie elle
est consommatrice d'équité elle est
consommée enfin les conservatrices de
tout un tas de trucs qui sont des
problèmes pas simples
pas trop les investissements les
investissements c'est pas trop le
problème
le temps est un problème absolument le
temps est un problème parce que ça
renvoie ce que je disais tout à l'heure
sur le débat démocratique vous pouvez
pas avoir un débat démocratique avec des
gens qui ne comprennent pas le enfin
vous pouvez la voir mais vous en sortez
rien
d'accord si je fais aujourd'hui un débat
démocratique dans cette salle en disant
voilà j'ai tous ces j'ai toussé ce matin
est-ce que j'ai une pleurésie est-ce que
j'ai un cancer du poumon est-ce que j'ai
avalé une mouche est-ce que j'ai etc et
on va décider au vote vous savez bien
que c'est pas comme ça qu'on soigne les
gens donc le le
débat démocratique il a sa limite
quand on
a besoin parce que c'est la nature du
problème qui le demande d'une couche de
compréhension du problème que les gens
n'ont pas spontanément pour être capable
de les mettre en responsabilité auquel
cas à ce moment on a des résultats
intéressants mais c'est c'est qu'on soit
pasteur de temps aussi
c'est très consommateur de temps je
m'offre la dernière question est-ce que
Jean-Marc Janco ici on a le droit
d'avoir de l'espoir encore il faut
je sais plus qui cette sortie qui disait
il est trop tard pour être pessimiste
non bon bien sûr qu'il faut mais je
en gros c'est nécessaire d'avoir de
l'espoir parce que c'est indispensable
quand on a un défi à relever de d'être
combatif voilà par contre c'est
nécessaire parce qu'on va jouer qu'une
fois
de pas se tromper sur le calibrage de
l'effort et de l'objectif d'accord
si en short et en basket vous fixez
comme défi de monter sur une montagne
qui a 3000 ou 3500 mètres d'altitude
vous avez de bonnes chances d'y arriver
si vous fixez dans la même tenue le défi
de monter sur l'Everest vous allez
laisser votre peau
donc
ça s'appelle plus à ce moment de la
compatibilité ça s'appelle de
l'inconscience
et c'est toujours la différence entre
les deux qui est pas nécessairement très
simple à établir donc bien sûr qu'il
faut être combatif par contre il faut
avoir du discernement donc il faut être
combatif pour des paris qui sont
gagnables et pas être combatif pour des
Paris dont on peut dire
que on a de très grandes chances de les
perdre d'avance voilà et c'est toute la
difficulté autour de laquelle on a pour
partie tourner ce soir
à la fois d'aller vite tout en prenant
le temps de réfléchir
de pas changer d'avis tout le temps tout
en se réservant la possibilité de le
faire si on se rend compte qu'on fait
une connerie enfin voilà c'est pas tout
ça tout ça n'est pas simple il n'y a pas
de voilà mais oui évidemment qu'il faut
être il faut avoir de l'espoir qu'il
faut être convoitif si on fait rien
merci beaucoup Jean-Marc Jancovici de
d'avoir passé du temps avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup à toutes et à tous pour
votre présence je rappelle que on a été
enregistré ce soir donc on aura le
loisir de se réécouter ou de nous
réécouter si vous le voulez je remercie
encore une fois nos collègues pour la
partie audiovisuelle
Antoine Camille et Jean-Louis qui ont
préparé cette table ronde assidûment et
puis merci encore Jean-Marc Lancôme ici
de votre présence bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]
c'est sur le site sur la chaîne Youtube